What if we told you that around 90 years ago
an epidemic swept across the world that killed
over a million people while affecting numerous
others, before disappearing, leaving the finest
scientific minds of the age absolutely stumped
. Then what if we told you that when it didn’t
kill you, this illness could instead potentially
trap you inside your body, stopping you from
having the will to move or speak.
You’d say we’d have to be lying because
no disease that terrifying could stalk the
Earth and have resulted in such an epidemic
without being front-page news and remembered
in the history books.
Well, it did exist and cases continue to be
brought forward even today; it remained one
of the biggest medical mysteries for nearly
a century, with scientists only very recently
getting an inkling of what causes the disease,
though none of the leading theories have been
definitively proven yet.
As you might expect from this, there is still
no cure.
Ladies and gentlemen, today we’d like to
talk about von Economo disease.
As you’ve probably guessed if you’re fantastically
well read, von Economo disease is named after
someone named von Economo- Constantin von
Economo- a psychiatrist, neurologist, and
one-time owner of a magnificent moustache,
who is widely credited as the first person
to thoroughly document the disease in question.
Economo published his findings on the disease
in April of 1917, just a few short years before
it became an epidemic, but several years after
it had first come to the attention of academics
and medical professionals.
In his paper, aptly named “Die Encephalitis
lethargica“, Economo christened this new
disease, Encephalitis lethargica, which means
something along the lines of “brain illness
that makes you sleepy”.
Today, the disease is mostly known as von
Economo disease, in Economo’s honor, and
Sleepy Sickness when someone doesn’t wish
to pay homage to Economo’s glorious facial
hair.
As a neurologist, the disease was of particular
interest to Economo and he discovered variations
on how the disease manifests including, among
other presentations,
• Hyperkinetic form: characterised by rapid
motor movements, uncontrollable twitching,
anxiousness, insominia and general restlessness.
• Amyostatic-akinetic form: leading to symptoms
remarkably similar to that of Parkinsons disease
and was characterised by dramatic reduction
in muscle strength and difficulty moving.
• Somnolent-ophthalmoplegic form: by far
the most lethal and involved the patient suddenly
falling asleep at random times, even while
walking.
In some, this would progress into the individual
slipping into an often fatal comatose state.
However, those who didn’t die quickly could
be left with an arguably worse fate, potentially
in a state of akinetic mutism, lacking the
will to move or express themselves in any
way for the rest of their lives.
A few years after Economo’s discovery and
paper, the disease was part of an epidemic
that swept across the world trapping many
thousands in their own bodies and killing
about a million total.
In the end, approximately 40% of those affected
died, 20% survived but were invalids, 26%
mostly recovered but with long term issues,
and the remaining 14% made full recoveries.
So with it affecting so many, why have you
never heard of it?
Well, the disease had amazing timing in that
it spread across the world around the same
time as the Spanish Flu pandemic.
For those of you who aren’t familiar with
it, the Spanish flu killed between 50-100
million (yes, million) people and infected
around a half a billion around the globe (roughly
1 in 4 humans at the time and possibly killing
as many as 1 in 20); it even reached places
as remote as the Arctic in-between 1918 and
1920.
So, even though Encephalitis Lethargica killed
its fair share of people and was hugely terrifying
in its own right, because it took place just
after a disease that affected a reasonably
large percentage of the world’s population,
it just wasn’t as noteworthy compared to
the super-disease that had just punched humanity
in our collective nether regions.
Due to their close proximity to each other,
the Spanish flu was initially linked to the
Encephalitis Lethargica outbreak, a theory
modern medical science thinks isn’t likely
though there are still some who think there
may have been a connection, via an autoimmune
response killing certain neurons in the brain.
However, given the lack of similarities between
the two in terms of systems effected, with
the only solid connection being they appeared
around the same time, most still think the
Spanish flu was not related.
That said, it does appear to be an immune
system response causing the problem.
In 2004, virologist John Oxford et al published
a paper on the results of their studying over
20 current patients with the disease and found
a similarity.
55% of them were known to have had sore throats
before the disease started more strongly presenting.
They then discovered that the sore throat
in every case had been caused by a rare form
of streptococcus (for you hypochondriacs out
there, try not to dwell on that one next time
you get strep-throat ;-)).
This rare form of streptococcus resulted in
a particularly strong immune system reaction,
which in turn resulted in the patient’s
immune system attacking certain parts of the
their brains, with the result being von Economo
disease.
Once the researchers discovered this, the
Holmes-like doctors checked and, sure enough,
the records indicated that during the early
20th century epidemic many of the patients
also reported sore throats before the disease
presented.
The eureka moment, though, came when they
found a reference that diplococcus microbes
had been documented among some of the patients-
a form of streptococcus.
So while it still hasn’t been definitively
proven, evidence strongly suggests that this
is the cause of the disease.
As mentioned, there was (and still is) no
actual cure or very effective treatment for
the disease, so after its reign of terror
was largely over around 1926, the world was
left with a far more pressing problem- the
thousands of living paper-weights the disease
hadn’t killed, still alive across the globe
and in a catatonic state.
That said, in patients suffering from the
hyper-kinectic form of the disease, certain
steroids have proven partially effective in
small studies and have been put forward as
a suggested course of treatment.
However, the fate of those trapped in their
own bodies is a lot less treatable, though
since the disease is similar in some ways
to Parkinsons, treatments for it have proven
somewhat effective in the past.
For example, in the 1960s, patients from the
original outbreak were granted small movement
for the first time in decades upon taking
the drug Levodopa; however, as a cruel twist
of fate, after only a few weeks of “waking
up,” the patients treated with the drug
developed a tolerance to it and slowly slipped
back into their paper-weight states.
If that sounds like a familiar plot-line,
it’s because the event was turned into a
book and later a movie called “Awakenings”
which was remarkably similar to the actual
events that occurred all those years ago with
these von Economo patients.
In the end, the disease is still around and
an outbreak of 1920s-like proportions is fully
possible today- and us still without a cure.